and meanwhile joe biden has visited
areas devastated by hurricane ida in
louisiana the tail end of the storm also
caused record rainfall and flash
flooding in new jersey and new york
nearly 50 people have been confirmed
dead in hundreds of thousands are still
without power
stunning destruction inflicted by the
record rainfall new jersey suffered this
week
dozens of people also died as ida tore
through the heavily populated state
authorities say the search for survivors
and the missing is not over yet
rescue crews continued to search in
neighboring pennsylvania too the flood
submerged cars and basement apartments
there
many were surprised by the staggering
speed with which the waters rose
i mean we were expecting something but
nothing this major so
lived here for quite some time and never
seen anything like this
in new york some areas are still
struggling with major power outages
and some subway lines are still out of
action after ida swamp them
the governor has admitted the state was
caught off guard this time
she's vowed to be better prepared next
time when the next major disaster hits
no longer will we say yeah that won't
happen again in our lifetime this could
literally happen next week
when you talk about the rainfall records
that were broken
central park for example
it broke a record that was set
the week before
and it almost doubled it that's how the
scale is going forward and we have to be
prepared for that ida was a tropical
storm when it hit the northeast
imagine the damage inflicted in the u.s
south there it was a factor four
hurricane
homes and businesses in this corner of
louisiana didn't stand a chance
about a million people in the state are
without power after the hurricane
destroyed electrical grids
oil production chains serving the city
of new orleans have also been damaged
meaning fuel shortages and long lines at
tank stations
president joe biden traveled to
louisiana on friday to see the scale of
the destruction there first hand he said
getting the hardest hit parts of the us
back on their feet should be everyone's
goal
this isn't about being a democrat or a
republican
we're americans and we'll get through
this together we just got to remember we
not only have to build back we have to
build back better than it was before
better than it was before so when
another super storm comes it's not the
damage done
hurricane ida has again made it
heartbreakingly clear just how
vulnerable the u.s is to extreme weather
events experts warn storms like ida will
become more frequent as climate change
intensifies reporter dave cohen is in
new orleans and joins us now welcome
dave
joe biden has seen some of the damages
first hand now what do people there need
from the federal government right now
they told him today the first thing they
need is electricity to be turned on and
right behind me now dozens of utility
trucks have just arrived here in
downtown new orleans to help in that
effort they also told him they need food
they need water and they need air
conditioning because it's very hot here
with temperatures in the 90s feeling
like the triple digits all week people's
tempers are flaring in fact you
mentioned the long lines of gas station
just moments ago we had a murder at a
gas station two people in a conflict
over getting gasoline and someone
apparently cutting in line led to
gunfire and now one person is dead
wow all right utility companies say it
may take until
mid next week for power to be restored
why is it taking so long
well that's just in the city of new
orleans it may be weeks longer in the
area's hardest hit by ida where it came
across the shoreline and did the most
destructive damage here in new orleans
the problem is a massive tower hundreds
of feet tall was knocked down during ida
and it carried eight transmission lines
into the city providing all of the
electricity for the region all of those
lines are now lying in the mississippi
river and they're not usable so crews
are having to find
power outside of this region and bring
it here on new long transmission lines
they close down the main highway into
new orleans today to string a new line
across the interstate so they can get
power here
dave uh since hurricane katrina 16 years
ago much of the infrastructure has been
improved in the region to withstand
these storms but with climate change
they are becoming more frequent what
more needs to be done long term
well they want here in new orleans the
worst of the damage was spared the
levees held this time for ida unlike
they did against hurricane katrina many
people since katrina have been saying
due to climate change and sea surface
levels rising we need better protections
against hurricanes this seems to be
proof that these new hardened taller
stronger levees around new orleans have
prevented 80 percent of the city being
flooded this time like there were in
katrina now
in
in areas outside of new orleans leaders
are begging for similar kinds of
protection fearing that we're going to
see more and more of these monster
storms moving forward
thanks dave reporter dave cohen in new
orleans
you